vabbè anni fa il successo che ero a casa
con il mio ragazzo
dopodiché lui se ne vada a casa mia e io
scrivo ad un altro ragazzo con cui stavo
uscendo in quel periodo e jean degli
amore se n'è appena andato ovviamente
quel messaggio mandato da primo già
aperta cioè quella del mio ragazzo con
ficiale non fatelo a ti spiego come
facevo luigi certamente 21 io e l'altro
è molto piccolo perché così almeno
riesco proprio a distinguere perdonami a
questo scempio dicono come questo sono
d'accordo con te vogliamoci bene viva
miss italia viene in questo mondo vivi
esci fuori di qua guarda che il mondo
non più le visto ci sono delle persone
belle ma sono l'unitá basta credere la
bontà delle persone e basta non si
dicono bugie le specie di questo tipo
non ci sto andiamo avanti
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è messaggi mandati nella
chat sbagliata
pronta così delicato pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios the casa mia
una persona che ha un rapporto con il
mio cellulare è abbastanza posso dire
tranquillo ecco non cerca ogni due
secondi di carne possesso stiamo
parlando niente popò di meno che di
luigi può comunque se sembra che siamo
appena svegli e così sto cercando di
guardare il più possibile guida così
preservare sveglio sei pronto via ti
senti pronto sono stanze pensi di
poterlo affrontare questa giornata
io non credo che non rende cent'anni
blackboard era un lago dei cigni a più
di cent'anni si doveva dire che orrenda
perché ha più di 100 anni
anche la monna lisa più di 100 anni
perdonate lo fa la moda e non in
macchina con quella che era la mia
fidanzata ci eravamo lasciati in quel
periodo non stavamo insieme ma comunque
ci vedevamo in macchina a fare
a fare le cose no dopo un po mi manda
messaggi mio padre un gruppo marginale e
appoggi il telefono sul sul cruscotto
senonché parte nel messaggio vocale
senza che io mi accorgo che nel
frattempo io vado parto dopo un po che
io finisco la compagna ragazza a casa
dormo e vedo quel momento dal cellulare
guido di andare al mio padre un
messaggio di 5 minuti mi uniscono apro e
sento praticamente di tutto dove
praticamente il rumore più normale e
questo per 5 minuti oltre tutti i gemiti
e la mia ragazza che si arrabbiano fine
perché qui condito in si sente lei che
mi urla in faccia dicendo ma sei scemo è
così che le cose del genere
io non so se lui l'ha letto non so
niente non ci ho mai parlato dal nodo
però mi sento fortunato perché poteva
capitare a chiunque altra persona che
non fosse mio padre ha quindi già mia
mamma era peggio
già 15 gli ultimi gruppi semina pregio
mi piace che il bicchiere mezzo pieno mi
sono fatto una risata
l'ottimismo ti salverà la seconda menti
per andare avanti per qualche tuo è
appena reso a parole quello che forse
uno dei miei terrori più grandi il fatto
che parta un vocale quando meno poi
controllarlo cioè che non deve per forza
essere una situazione capitoli ma che
parta un vocale di 10 minuti per dirti
ma questa dice per quanto riguarda
comunque messaggi inviati alla persona
sbagliata
[Musica]
quella persona credo fosse un ragazzo
con cui mi sentivo però io non ero
interessata al suo ennesimo messaggio
che visualizzavo e non rispondevo faccia
lo screen domanda ma ne amica dico ma
questo ha proprio rotto lo accorgermi a
risposta ricevuta per hanno inviato in
realtà a lui stesso però così poi non ho
più scritto il problema risarcita chi le
ha travolte com'era la sfortuna può
aiutare 160 gradi e trasformarsi così
infortuni un'altra ottimista cronica
appena è vera giorno al mare a casa mia
vicino a roma con le mie migliori amiche
magre migliorami che sarà lasciata poco
molto fidanzato che le ha ovviamente c'è
stata molto male e quindi stati pensato
quella sera di mandargli un messaggio ed
abbiamo provato a fermarla ma non ci
siamo riusciti
il soggiorno allego qui sotto aspetta
aspetta aspetta vista questa è pro
presenti il bel questi sono amiche vere
ti fermano prima di far danni marvel
aveva fatto che l'ha mandato e scusa
ciao ciao
quando questo screenshot che come avete
preso da uno di quei soliti gruppi tutti
quanti abbiamo di famiglia allargata con
nonni zii cugini grandi piccoli bambini
e una mattina mi sveglio e trovo questo
diciamo messaggio di buongiorno sul mio
sul mio telefono niente chiuderti che è
stato mandato da mio zio che ha un tipo
ottantina di anni mentre il messaggio di
sotto ed alla figlia che cerca in
qualche modo di non so mettere pezze a
quello che è successo io l'ho generò sei
pronto lo zio di 80 anni si è superato
ma credo che abbia sbagliato un po
scrivere perché forse scriveva tipo con
una mano e mezzo il primo con mezza mano
anzi duro e bello io sono figlia scusate
evidentemente il tè di papà qualcosa che
non va
li ho chiamati per eliminare i messaggi
ma mamma la mamma lo rispondere cripta
la mia voce
addirittura i nostri potenti mezzi
trasformeranno la tua voce da questo a
quest'altra cosa vai arrivo
ciao e niente messaggiando sostantivo
che poi la mia migliore amica intanto
anche il mio ormai ex scrivo questo
messaggio che leccate ovviamente l'ho
mandato alle ore è la risposta è stata
buona ma ci prende un po di più la
prossima volta
questo può essere un messaggio
costruttivo fra chiamato lo psicologo
scusa tu non mi hai mandato
una certa sbagliata no in realtà no
magari questi gruppetti ultimamente un
po di casini sì ma fortunatamente no io
no perché noi amici ho detto andiamo
avanti
chissà che non mi ricordo se ho mandato
cioè sicuramente lavoro fatto e un mio
amico è una persona che conosco non
faccio nomi
una volta ha mandato diciamo un suo
selphy scattato un po dal basso ok a a
un suo contatto di lavoro l'ha
cancellato subito aveva fatto scusami
noti ha mandato il documento sbagliato e
gli ha mandato un altro documento su
tipo delle rendicontazioni sistema
ciao bonanno e tanto 7 visto questo
ragazzo mi è capitato mandare se tipo
foto ecco non mandato a sua madre
messenger se va bene se l'hai capito
almeno apprezzato che bella ci sta che
ci ha messo il live cam si no
ma la mia figlia gustaio questo è uno
dei motivi per cui mai avere i numeri di
telefono di cuocere consuocere cose così
io sono voluto madre si cela lo zombie
oddio questo il messaggio vecchio l'ho
mandato questo questo che lo stava
facendo vedere solamente per far
riprendere bene enel senza non c'entra
niente col tema di questo video ma
sembra un po tu
ora devo al messaggio che ha badato in
realtà veramente questa ragazza ospite
spera di essere ancora il tempo per
questo audio comunque durante il periodo
in cui stavo col mia prima ragazzina di
16 anni è successo che erano una casa
sua da soli e stavamo facendo le nostre
cosine romantiche mi è arrivato un
messaggio da un e menica chiedendomi se
la libera per uscire con lei che al
tempo stesso un messaggio di mia madre
chiedendomi doverla perché non ero a
casa ho sbagliato a inviare il messaggio
al destinatario e ho il mio atto il
messaggio mia madre che ho scritto
guarda anna sto io tipo non sono tornata
a casa prodotto brizzi non hai ancora
fuori latitante lei sono anni ormai che
non torna mai capitato di inviare alla
persona che avevo screenato cose simili
ora vogliamo parlare di quel periodo
oscuro che ognuno di noi passa e non
dite che non è vero in cui le altre
persone non ti minimamente e quindi
fingi di aver sbagliato inviare il
messaggio cioè tipo il mio messaggio che
fai finta che non era destinato a quella
del suo no così tanto per farvi capire
esiste anche tu una professionista è
capitato a tutti e lo so una
professionista tu non l'hai mai fatto è
una delle tattiche migliori all'inizio
però posso dire una cosa quando usi
quella tattica di essere molto bravo
però perché ammette poi non ho mai
funzionato maio fare un mai detto ciao
due ospiti volevo raccontare di quando
avevamo il gruppo di classe con la
nostra professoressa di italiano
il mio compagno di classe scrisse
il gruppo con la professoressa sì e noi
con moltissime inizio ma che fai
mamme che con il gruppo quando
professoressa e lui subito si corresse
scrivendo si scherza con un asterisco
la specifica disco una bella a
l'asterisco di una bella mossa perché
cioè trasformare per scherzo cioè sono
molte del singolo minonne un bel po di
anni fa quando ancora non si potevano
cancellare i messaggi su stanno
arrivando scusate un sacco di frasi che
dicono quando ancora non si potevano
cancellare i messaggi
possiamo dire che quello di cancellare i
messaggi su sap è stato un atto di
civiltà da parte dei programmatori e
degli ideatori di whatsapp assolutamente
e oppure ragionato su una cosa quale è
forse arrivato il momento ideale non so
se siete pronti ok che quando tu
cancelli per tutti e perché in realtà
dove cancellarlo all'altro contatto
certo ma chi lo cancella solo per se
stesso e per non farsi sgamare ma allo
stesso tempo non farsi sgamare dall'alta
persona che sta cancellando i messaggi e
quindi gli ideatori di bozzano
alta inviati il fidanzato di una mia
amica invia una foto del pupazzo dvd
abbracciato al suo pene eretto sono che
invece di inviarlo a lei l'ha inviato su
un gruppo dove c'erano sia lei sia tutta
una serie di amici in questa compensato
dalle vere tipo vd abbracciato al tuo
pudiche presenti gli stand due mondi voi
quel mondo giusti ha tradite eccetto i
siti più 38 cioè cast i video dp che
cosa ne fece una pulp a scosse ma loro
smash volevo mondo attacchi sono su
facebook
a loro la fauci compiango jan mista se
lo schifo di infuso meditango qui avete
qui devecchi stocker zampar vedi che
questa degli elettrico e lega la
turnazione nvidia con che se volete
votare fammi sapere che poi fatto tutta
la francia ma in che modo
ma perché io già mi sentivo la star
europee grazie
niente mi ha rovinato la posso sapere
perché io non parlo mi niente francese
non ci capisco niente
che cos'è che ha detto se qualcuno lo
può tradurre mi farebbe un favore che
basta non si e insulti novoli sensori
insulti in sapevo il tuo facebook
vediamo che ride per ultimo ma una delle
mie belle scegliere più recenti
rapidamente ma da una faccio tante foto
dal sì mestrino e non ne accorgo che in
una di queste si vede in bella mostra il
pacco di profilattici
quando fini era tutto buio e solo il
flash ha rivelato questo particolare
vabbè comunque buona nostro migliore
pure lei sono caramelle nella tasca
dell'auto e poi questa foto
sì se i genitori che devono ma che i
genitori che giocano a un due tre stella
cioè che devi per forza ton alle persone
a un certo punto un minimo di tatto è
che ho amato all'estero caramelle due ex
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
e ragazzi se c'è una cosa che ho
imparato è che non sono i robottini che
ti puniscono casa che hanno che hanno
permesso alla razza umana di andare
avanti ma la possibilità di cancellare i
messaggi su whatsapp questo è sinonimo
di civiltà
il mio modo di fare attenzione alle
gocce d'acqua cioè non ve lavate più
presto io come sempre vi ringrazio per
aver seguito questo video vi chiedo di
farmi sapere con un commento qua sotto
quali sono stati magari quelle
esperienze legate dei messaggi ai
mandate nelle città sbagliate o magari
se avete suggerimenti per dei prossimi
temi in futuro come sempre vi invito a
iscrivervi attivare le notifiche con la
campanellina qua sotto
e qui come riporta mai ti ringrazio per
essere venuto qui potete aver fatto
questo video insieme e adesso andiamo a
magna se e ci vediamo con la prossima
puntata di vita buttata giù di prossimo
ciao
aspetta no è una cosa per te
[Musica]
stiamo dando
ma questa carinissima rifarla subito il
maestro si ripete